[Music]
we might see her in Boston coming up we
might not okay do you know it's funny
because I everyone keeps asking about
Ellen leaving but I still feel that
she's so present like right because
she's still an executive producer
I just the other day I saw her she was
like biking on like through the stages I
was like
it was known for it strong women on
screen and off and tonight on ABC Kim
joins Ellen Chandra Wilson and Debbie
Allen directing her first episode of the
show I was definitely watching them
while they were directing and it was
like a master class so we got chief of
surgery on screen first time director
off screen you are the ultimate boss
lady right now oh thanks I really I had
the best time it was hilarious at like
at one point I had like my fake
walkie-talkie as Teddy Chief and then I
had my real walkie-talkie to like talk
to the crew as director it just felt
very much like real life was you know I
was imitating like Teddy but as me and
directing this cast and having this
amazing crew was really it was a dream
for me and you know Debbie Allen was my
mentor is my mentor and you've been
shadowing her for a while now right yeah
I think people feel like oh you're on
graze like you'll get to direct and you
really have to earn it with her which is
amazing stay open call for backup and
keep me posted this episode is huge I
know girl this is no filler episode Ray
Sloan is on a hospital-wide lockdown
they weren't like oh it's your first
episode here we're gonna give you like a
little tiny thing we're on location we
have two stunts we have a song we have
Kate Walsh comes back although it does
say in the promo No One Is Safe
so how much do we have to worry about
perhaps one of our favorite characters
I'm making it out alive it's pretty
intense it's definitely not an episode
that you want to miss there's this
fantastic Cliffhanger and it's
interesting because you know I I got to
design it and I got to design how I
wanted the episode to go out and we
definitely I sort of take it to the edge
yeah it's really exciting yeah oh my
gosh and it's a two-parter I hope that
everyone is like wait what fans are
already brilling with the news that
season 19 will be the last for Dr Maggie
how much are you gonna miss her presence
on the show I'm gonna miss her so much
she is such a talent and such a
wonderful human being but at the same
time I'm so excited for I think she has
so many incredible incredible you know
roles and Adventures uh I think we're
all so sad to see her go but we are so
excited for her because I just think
she's just you know she's gonna take off
with her talent but of course like at
this time of year I feel like viewers
get a sense of okay so is this or is
this not the end of Grace how long would
you like the show to continue oh
we all joke about that look I mean we
would all love season 20 there it feels
like something very momentous about a a
season 20. I just feel like
there's sort of inherently in Gray's
Anatomy an amazing way to tell human
stories and I feel like that just can
keep going
thank you